طبعنا نحن اليوم في الشرق الاوسط نحب
الاكل دائما عزايمنا فيها اكل وعزايمنا
عامره بالاكل مختلف انواع منطقه الشرق
الاوسط يمكن اقل حجما عن امريكا لكن
الثقافات اللي فيها تفوق كثير من الدول او
حتى بعض القارات
التنوع الثقافي تنوع طرق الطبخ حبنا للاكل
هو اللي خل الامور تزدهر بشكل اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
صاير كثير على الموضه يعني بشر هون
بالخليج بالملليس وبالرا بالغرب في تقليده
بس كمان في يعني
في شويه تجديد مش مثل غير محلات بس انه عم
يبلشوا
من اهم الشغلات اللي حاليا المطاعم بتركز
عليها هي الاستدامه او الاكل الخضروات او
البجديري بشكل عام عشان احنا بالوضع
الحالي الايام هاي لازم يكون جدا مساندين
لامنا الارض عشان هي بحاجتنا بافكار
وصيحات كثيره طلعت وما استسغناها وفشلت مع
الوقت وفي صيحات ما استغناها ونجحت مع
الوقت فهالاشياء نتركها للسوق اليوم في
جهد او مجهود كبير ينطرح ويتم عمله في من
العن قبل المزارع اللي ما استصيغه لما
يكون
مثلا توصل هناك في المطبخ او في في المطعم
ويعبوا لك اياه صوص يعبوا لك اياها اشياء
مالها داعي في روح المجهود او الطعم
الاساسي
الوحيد اللي ما بحبه يعني في كتير اشياء
يعني
بالسوبر ماركت هلا على الموضه
بيعملوا اكلات من الايسن بس ما كثير يعني
بخلطه لانه يمكن ما بيفهموا كتير شو هو
اللبناني وشو هو التركي وشو هو المغربي
سوق بيخلطوا لبنان على مغربي على تركيا سو
هيك اشياء انا بلاقيهم شوي مزعجين اللي
انا حاليا عم بشوفه صراحه بكثير مطاعم وجب
الوطن العربي انهم بحاولوا يبعدوا عن
هويتهم جذورهم وهذا اشي بالنسبه لك غلط
ليش عشان انا برايي ما في شف نجح ووصل او
وصل للنجاح اللي هو بده اياه الا اذا هو
التزم وتمسك بهويته وجذوره وبتاريخه